[Musique]
il a bête mais est né en 1954 au
connecticut aux états unis elle a 19 ans
quand sa famille emménage au cap breton
en nouvelle écosse
très tôt elle se fait connaître pour son
combat contre l'épandage d'insecticides
et d'herbicides dans cette province en
1986 elizabeth may devient conseillère
auprès du ministre fédéral de
l'environnement dans le gouvernement
mais elle démissionne deux ans plus tard
pour protester contre un projet de
barrages en saskatchewan
elizabeth may renoue alors avec
l'activisme elle sera directrice du
sierra club canada pendant 17 ans en
2006 elle prend les rênes du parti vert
mais elle devra patienter cinq ans avant
de faire entrer son parti aux communes
en se faisant élire en colombie
britannique
[Musique]